in Istanbul campaigning is in full swing
with opposition leaders rallying their
supporters
is the main rival to president
erduran he leads the secular Republican
people's party or CHP
and also the National Alliance a group
of parties also known as the table of
six
the 74 year old Economist has promised
to give people more freedom Crackdown on
inflation and encourage foreign
investors to return to Turkey
not going to leave the fate of the
Turkish Republic in the hands of one
person and no one will accept the words
of just one person
it took members of the opposition block
months to set aside their differences
and agree Uncle as a candidate
in March the chp's major partner the
Nationalist good party or ear threatened
to leave the coalition
returned only after kilish daroglu
selected the popular mayors of Istanbul
and Ankara ekram Imam and mansoyavash as
his choices for vice president
Coalition and its candidates
if they win the parties say they will
undo the legacy of President erdogan and
their party but if the opposition loses
their Alliance they disintegrate and
kill his dad all his political career
may come to an end
supporters of the National Alliance see
the presidential and parliamentary
elections on May the 14th as their
chance to defeat president erdoran and
his party who have been in power for 22
years
if he wins it will be very very good
everything will be nice and democracy
will prevail
were former allies of President
they now lead small parties but their
support for kilish could be decisive as
the race becomes tighter
al-jazeera Istanbul
Allah is live for us an anchor now and
as you mentioned in your story there
this is an incredibly close election
what is it like on the streets in the
lead up to it
yeah
Tom this is quite a decisive moment I've
been in Istanbul a few days ago now I'm
in Ankara I've been
[Music]
going to different areas joining some
candidates during their rallies
listening to the people and across the
political Spectrum here in turkey and
they can tell you that they are excited
and worried excited because they think
this could be a decisive moment in the
modern history of Turkey
polls have been suggesting that this
could be a tight a raise and this is why
people are worried at the same time
because they're looking forward to see
what happens on the 14th of May now
as far as the opposition is concerned
they say that this could be their moment
the United the heart bringing about
faces from different uh walks of life I
was at one of the biggest rallies in
Istanbul and you can see the
choreography was really important
particularly Alibaba and um
former allies of President
erdoran walking the stage along with
their wives were their veils it was an
attempt by the table of six or the
alliance coalition to cut across the
political Spectrum in Turkey build
Bridges with the conservatives and tell
them you know what we would like to win
your hearts and Minds when we like to be
as United
are stronger than before to be able to
defeat
but the supporters of the Ark party and
president
said that this is someone who has
dominated political life for the last
two decades in turkey and that he has
managed time and again to navigate
through the massive challenges and win
elections he has won 10 major elections
in the past and they say that he's
definitely going to win this election
but I have to say that the biggest
chance for the opposition this time is
to manage to go to the second round if
they do it that would be a major
development for them because their
biggest concern is
the two other main candidates in the
presidential elections NJ and also sinan
are potentially candidates that could
split votes and deny the opposition
significant those they really need
particularly knowing that this could be
a tie to race but they say that they can
manage to go to the second round their
chances for winning these elections are
huge same thing applies for the clam the
camp of President and the ACT party they
are determined to win the elections on
the first round they will be very
concerned if they go to the second run
because when you go to the second round
you will have new political realignments
and most of the supporters of all the
other candidates will definitely have to
join the opposition and vote for them
okay thank you so much for that update
that is Hashem alabara for us in Ankara